The layout shifter pattern is probably
the most responsive pattern with
multiple break points across several
different screen widths, but
the key to this layout is the way
that content moves about instead of
reflowing and
dropping below other columns.
Flex box really shines here, because
we can use the order CSS attribute.
Amazing.
Because so
much can change in each layout, it does
require a bit more planning to maintain.
I'll go for
something a bit more complex this time.
In order to get the layout I want,
I've wrapped the light blue div, and
the green div inside container two.
I've made one small change to the
container class from the last example.
And I've set it's width to 100%,
so that the element inside
takes up the full width.
When no break point has been hit,
only the default styles are applied
making each element 100% width.
Stacked on top of the other.
When the first media query is hit
at 500 pixels, the break point
changes the dark blue and
the container, each to be width of 50%.
The red div remains at 100%,
because we haven't changed it.
At 600 pixels things
start to get really fun.
To get everything to fit, I need to
change the width on container2 to 50%
and the width on dark blue and
red to 25% each.
Next, to change the order, I need to
specify an order for each element.
Remember, the default order value for
an element is zero.
If I set order to negative 1 on
the red div it'll appear first.
To get the dark blue element,
to show up last,
I need to set it's value to
anything greater than zero, so one.
Let's take a look in the browser.
It's all stacked to start.
But as it gets wider, and
hits the first break point,
the dark blue goes to
the left with light blue and
green on the right,
until finally it switches up again.
Nice!